thank you you sound great you feel good
nice that's nice I was little depressed
today yeah I told my friend I was
depressed he said Nick remember no
matter how bad it gets there's always
someone worse off than you so now I'm
depressed and worried about this other
poor guy if he dies I'm screwed
it's my own fault don't tell people you
depress it they never did you put too
much pressure on them I know this guy
also said um you should work out more
you should exercise oh yeah that's a
good idea I hate my life now let's
extend it
Wow look at the tight ass on that sad
guy I work out anyway I do I do work out
I work out a little I'm not I don't go
crazy with it I try to be in decent
shape you know I don't need to be in
great shape I'm in my 40s you know I
don't need to be great but I have white
hair what about white hair and six-pack
ABS I look like I'm from the future
I don't even know if I'm depressed you
know I think you know what I am I'm an
adult
yeah I think the base energy goes down
you know it's hard to get excited about
stuff when you're an adult you know
credit card debt and heart disease and
what do you get excited about as an
adult a real adult 30 and above not
counting cue what do you get excited
about sex money booze dessert sure those
are the biggies sex money booze and
dessert yeah and sex and money are
complicated so most of us end up drunk
and chubby right just beer and cake fill
the hole it's just getting older you
know you just you think you're young
you're young it's nice you know you
think oh it's gonna be awesome when I
get older I'm gonna meet the right
person and have a lot of money in
dessert
it's dessert you're gonna be like me
welcome the grocery store aisles at
midnight like it's last call at a
singles bar
well who do we have here
Double Stuf indeed let's go it's true
but you know yeah just the thing is I
think you have to you can't compare
yourself to other people that's another
big trap for not feeling good you know
cuz you see other people their lives and
you go why thank you LeBron James why
does he get to don't think about that
you know Brad Pitt think about Brad Pitt
imagine that Brad Pitt great looking
rich famous Oscar sleeping with Angelina
Jolie holy moly
what did this guy do pull a thorn out of
God's paw or his parents leprechauns
it's ridiculous so did that joke the
other night some woman said you just
jealous gee I think
yes of course I'm jealous
what other reaction is there to Brad
Pitt gratitude good for him
finally that guy got a break now I can
focus on my old problems amazing life
though Brad Pitt's gonna be I don't know
one in the billion to have that kind of
resume life Wow you think Brad Pitt
prays
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you